to the season America in just 30 minutes
from now the five we'll be dashing our
way to Fox Square for the All American
Christmas tree lighting all of your
favorite Fox News hosts they're going to
be there and there will be plenty of fun
and some surprises but before we head
outside let's get to some big news of
the day well it was not the kind of
birthday he was hoping for President
Biden turning 81 years old today and he
just cannot catch a break from the
Avalanche of bad headline surrounding
his re-election campaign aign just about
every mainstream Outlet writing articles
about his Advanced age former senior
adviser to President Obama David axod is
calling the president too old saying
Biden has a 5050 shot at reelection and
check out this Wall Street Journal
headlined which says quote Biden keeps
talking about the old days young voters
they don't like it but the president is
brushing off those concerns while at the
Thanksgiving turkey
pardon by the way I it's my birthday
birthday today and they can actually
sign
birthday I just want you to know it's
difficult turning 60 it's difficult the
National Turkey presentation is and
pardon marks The Unofficial start of the
holiday season we're here in Washington
a time to share joy and gratitude and
have a little bit of
fun this is the 76th anniversary of this
event and I want you to know I wasn't
there in the first
one I was too young to make it up
President Biden has been trying to just
make some jokes about his age but it's
no laughing matter to his White House
according to a new report staffers have
launched their own operation dubbed the
bubble wrap strategy in order to protect
the oldest ever president from tripping
in public which if you remember Ma and
Joe on MSNBC when he tripped at that on
the stage at that one thing they said
they blamed the staff and said how dare
you not have a way for him to be
protected from Falls like that but happy
birthday to the presid president yeah
are you looking at me yeah you can talk
but say anything you want I really wish
I was at the children's
table uh Joe's age is his biggest
liability let's be honest you know aside
from the open border bad economy the war
in Ukraine the war in Israel the botched
Afghanistan withdrawal Rising crime rate
payoffs from China the price of gas and
his corrupt family but other than that
I'm really worried about is the age I
think this story is a bit of a scam
there's a way better argument to be made
than aging and the number specifically
because that can be bounced back to you
I mean Trump is a few years behind and
you have to if you focus on competence
and function that's the real argument
because Biden is old but so is Bernie
Sanders and so is MC Jagger and you look
at Trump I mean Trump is doing standup
while Joe can barely stand up as for the
bubble wrap that was good line by the
way thank you uh more like trouble wrap
I mean and what is the bubble WP
protecting is it Joe or who's
controlling Joe so I think the greater
Mission here is to protect those who are
behind the scenes telling him what to do
and what to say I think the feebleness
argument now the age argument is there
to kind of keep us busy and as a
misdirection from the fact that there's
a whole group of people that are
basically directing his every movement
so I'm I'm more worried about that than
I am his age let me show you the NBC
poll call for here Trump beating Biden
for with younger people ages 18 to 34
that percentage with Trump at 46 Biden
at
44 that's the presidential preference
poll and the 18 to 24 year olds it's
actually 46 to 42 so that's a key voting
block for the president and Jesse when
it comes to a very close election if you
lose just a few of those voters it could
be a bad bad news for Joe Biden yeah his
base is fracturing the Palestinian
situation is not helping it need either
is crime the border and high prices but
it doesn't also help when every story he
tells is about a lunch she had with a
segregationist or satchel pagee and
these things aren't connecting with
people and they used to compare Joe
Biden to FDR remember that because of
all of his great domestic
accomplishments I think the app
comparison is with FDR but it's about
how both of these presidents concealed
their health from voters remember
remember FDR was in a wheelchair and
always tried to cover that up Joe Biden
the bubble wrap campaign is the same
thing the guy has brunch Lids if it's
not a 4-day weekend it's a three-day
weekend he never talks to us so the
American people feel deceived and we
want to feel connected to the president
we want to feel like we know the
president we understand him and he's in
our face but this guy doesn't ever
appear in public and when he does appear
in public he won't take questions and if
he does he goes I'm going to get in
trouble so it makes us feel like he's
not really in charge now the American
people are realizing and especially the
Democrats that the only reason Joe won
in the first place was because of covid
and the FBI and this election there will
not be covid and the FBI well musk
bought Twitter so there's not the
infrastructure there to help Joe Biden
win and now the focus is on Joe Biden's
performance and everyone's focused on
his age his gate his speech and his
performance is just not inspiring
confidence so everybody's going to try
to hide him and I just see Donald Trump
who has to run against the
world and he has a better shot running
against the world than Joe Biden has
against running against father time
because no one's ever beaten Father Time
Harold Fort Jr listen to Bill Maher this
weekend he said had some pretty tough
words for the president I've said it
before do I think Joe Biden can do the
job absolutely I don't think he can win
the job and that's what I care about
he's going to lose because the people
think he's too old and perception is
reality I'm sorry you hearing from
democratic circles he's going to be back
he he reflects what a lot of people in
the party believe what a lot of people
in the party are starting to believe and
David Axelrod who said it a few weeks
ago was criticized by some but privately
people are saying this I think there
three takeaways from from the poll that
I find most interesting first he's
losing to Trump uh this was not
happening three or four months ago and
he's just pulling data and the president
would always say I could beat Trump I
deserve the opportunity to go after to
to to to have this rematch two the key
issues you guys mentioned put aide to
age one one moment because I've always
thought it was policy accurity more so
than than age accurity or mental
accurity that really mattered you
touched on uh MC Jagger and others who
have of age but seem more youthful than
president than President Biden but the
border and crime and other issues these
are serious things they've got to figure
out how they address the other thing
from the poll if you take out Trump and
you have another Republican against
Biden they win by seven or eight points
if you take out Biden and they go
against Trump they win by six or seven
points a Democrat so at some points the
point that Axel Rod was making is one
that Democrats are going to have to
Grapple with um sooner much sooner
rather than later finally what President
Biden constantly over the last few weeks
has pointed to the last two weeks has
been that on Election Day the only data
that we have the polling data but we
have an election they that and Democrats
did fairly well two weeks ago they won
in Virginia they won that abortion
battle in Ohio and they reelected the
Kentucky Governor the question is does
that translate to Joe Biden Joe Biden
argues it does and his team argues that
it does I don't know what I do know is
the most recent polling data says the
president is losing to Donald Trump and
one of the most important age groups
that has mattered to Democrats the most
and that's at 18 to 34 group judge I'll
open it up to you I'll just point out
that in the Fox News poll last week
Republicans were doing better on every
one of those important issues than the
Democrats sometime all of them by double
digits okay right now we're talking
about Joe Biden and in the New York
Times Sienna poll of the Battleground
States 71% said Biden was too old by
contrast 39% said the same thing about
Donald Trump so the public recognizes is
that this is about cognition it's not
about age the public has been watching
this man falling down tripping stumbling
slurring his words not going to dinners
and international events and they're not
going to be fooled by this new bubble
wrap campaign strategy uh we got conned
by the first one when it was a basement
campaign but you know fool me once shame
on you fool me twice shame on me and I
think the American people uh what they
believe is reflected in this New York
Times siant poll now in addition to the
fact that he definitely is not getting
any younger you know we can refer to
people like Mick shagger and everybody
else just last week at the Patriot
Awards we had a 99-year-old World War II
veteran who came on stage and and he
walked out he didn't stumble out we
weren't like waiting for him to trip he
walked out gave a speech ad Li had the
audience standing in a you know a
standing ovation that's what America
needs not this man Andy Negra for
president Andy yes indeed all right hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now